okay so we are gonna start in 1891 when
a German scientist was looking through a
microscope at insects cells and he saw
something kind of funny at the center of
the cells there was this dark stuff no
one had ever seen it before and he
noticed that as the cells would multiply
and divide it would go into some of the
new cells but not the others
I didn't know what it was so he gave it
a really great name he called it the X
element and he was like we'll just fill
in that X later and then fast-forward 10
years later and there is an American
scientist and she is looking through her
microscope also at insect cells and she
sees something funny there's more of
this dark stuff and it's kind of tiny
it's hanging out near the X element and
eventually someone was like well if that
one thing is called X like should we
call this other thing Y and like that
the sex chromosomes had been discovered
so chromosomes you probably all know
what they are but I will tell you
anyways they're made up of DNA
everything has it it's the blueprint of
life we've got rats we've got trees
we've got insects we've got humans and
in the case of human chromosomes
geneticist Melissa Wilson broke it down
for me like this typically you'll get
one copy of every chromosome from your
genetic mom and one copy of every
chromosome from your genetic dad and we
have 22 of these that you get one copy
from mom and one copy from dad and then
there's a 23rd pair x and y so while all
the other chromosomes are numbered 1
through 22 we do not call x and y 23 I
like to think that they were waiting for
like a LeBron James to come along but in
this instance they were like we're just
gonna keep the letters and then we'll
give them a title they call them the sex
chromosomes now I would wager that in
the United States these are the most
well known chromosomes for one simple
fact that we say x equals girl and y
equals boy the
they are responsible for sex and and I
had to learn this but when I'm talking
about sex here I'm talking about the way
biology gives us gonads right which are
our ovaries and our testes I'm not
talking about gender which is how we
identify and so as a reporter at the
show radio lab the audio documentary
program I work for I was like what's up
with these sex chromosomes you know like
that's kind of my job I think things are
weird and then I get to call people
about them and ask questions and then
hopefully they answer and in this case a
lot of people answered and in the two
years I had of reporting on X&Y as part
of gonads the series on sex and gender I
ended up doing for radio lab I found out
that these two chromosomes live in a
world that is unexpected a little
unsettling were things that I thought
were facts were like twisted in ways I
hadn't seen before and the world goes so
far beyond the boundaries of sex I was
like you should all talk about this so
you're you all we're all gonna talk
about it and for me the true story of
X&Y
starts with their name so within years
of being discovered these two little
chromosomes had acquired more than ten
different names
there was diplom and hetero chromosome
in ideo chromosome and most of the names
had to do with their structure their
shape their size and then there was sex
chromosome which they had been given
because of the fact that we had started
seeing that the X would go with the
females and the Y would often go with
the males but scientists were like do we
really want to call them sex chromosomes
and science historian Sarah Richardson
is the one who told me this story for
three decades scientists were like you
should not call them the sex chromosomes
the X&Y have many functions and you know
you wouldn't assume that a single
chromosome controls a single trait
imagine calling one chromosome the
urogenital chromosome or the liver
chromosome scientists if you dig into
the
it's really cool you should were
hesitant to like commit to such a
specific name and such a powerful ikana
tative name there was a fear that it
would actually be really limiting maybe
to science maybe to society but the but
the fear was in the room and you can see
they ended up getting sex chromosome
it's like a pretty juicy title I mean it
was it it popularized genetics you know
but in the 100 year history since we
settled on that name you can see it
start to get a little complicated so
around 1960 this is gonna be our first
kind of stopped on the complicated world
of the sex chromosomes so around 1960 we
had discovered that you could be XY Y
they discovered an XY Y man and to
digress a little here it turns out that
the model of X equals girl and y equals
boy is really simplistic you can
actually be a whole bunch of different
combinations of x and y giving you like
different types of biological sex you
can be two x's and two y's together you
could be four X's you could be five X's
you could be X zero and so I thought
that was pretty crazy because I was like
wow this really up ends a model of
biological sex I think most of us in
this room have been taught so a few
years after they realized that you can
be XY Y researchers go to a prison in
Scotland and they do genetic analysis of
a bunch of the male prisoners and they
find a number of people who are XY Y and
according to Sarah they just rushed to
publish a theory suggesting that this
extra Y chromosome could explain
criminality in some men yeah so the
logic goes like this by this point we're
thinking why is male we think male is
aggressive so y must be aggression if
you got an extra Y you must be crazy and
like we went nuts with this theory we
called it the super male they started
scanning more prisoners serial killers
boys
and in all seriousness there was
actually a suggestion that we consider
aborting XYY fetuses so in 1980 this
theory pretty much toppled for a number
of reasons one there had been this
really large study that basically showed
there was no connection between why and
and violence I think we all saw that
coming
and then there was one other thing going
back and looking at those original
findings and that high-security
psychiatric institution they had also
found a high number of individuals with
an extra X chromosome so these are X X Y
as opposed to XY Y really yeah now they
never claimed that the individuals with
an extra X chromosome were super females
they never investigated whether they had
higher rates of violence seems like kind
of an oversight I don't know but I think
it's interesting because what you see is
if you start looking at these
chromosomes through the lens of sex what
naturally falls in place behind as we
look at them through the lens of gender
and the traits that we associate with
gender so men were violent and why
explained while they were in prison the
X did not do that because like you know
what's X we don't associate it with
violence and while we don't believe in
super males today god I hope we don't we
don't believe in super males today there
is a very similar conversation that's
still happening around inherent violence
in boys and biology so my next stop on
the weird world of X and y or things
feeling a little topsy-turvy is 1985 the
World University Games were set to
happen in Japan and the Spanish hurdler
Maria Jose Martinez Pitino was scheduled
to run she was like a hotshot a rising
superstar and the night before her race
they had her DNA scanned now at the time
this was a thing that they were doing
because they were like okay we don't
want men covertly racing as women so
we're gonna scan the women and make sure
all their exes
not and so I heard this story from Ruth
Padua who is a New York Times magazine
reporter and she reported on Maria
so they tell her the chromosome test
results were abnormal although on the
outside she was fully female she had XY
chromosomes and these internal testes
they were like we hate to break it to
you Maria but you're actually a dude you
can't race with the ladies
and so she's thrown off the national
team she's expelled from the Athletics
residence she's denied her scholarship a
bunch of her friends dumper fellow
athletes abandon her she loses her
medals her records are revoked so it
turns out remember I told you it can be
a bunch of different combinations of X
and y you can also be XY and be female
you can be xx and male in Maria's case
she was something called androgen
insensitive which means that she did
have some sort of internal testes they
were making testosterone but her body
couldn't use it and so if you thought of
testosterone is like a superpower she
was not benefiting from it and so
eventually sports authorities like let
her back in but her career was done
and in this instance you see how if you
assign sex to a specific place in the
body or at least like this is what I saw
right if you assign sex to a specific
place in the body it somehow makes us
think that we can go into a body look at
a specific place and tell someone we
know something more about them than they
know about themselves and that feels
terrifying to me and we don't
genetically test female athletes anymore
but you can see very similar
conversations happening when we talk
about testosterone in sports you can
also see it in suggestions that we take
transgender individuals and we
genetically analyze them and we tell
them who they are
that is real that is a conversation that
has happened recently the last place
that I'll share with you release
chromosomes comp
kaida for me is this one thing that
Melissa told me you can't survive
without an X chromosome no matter you're
going as no matter your identity every
single human being has to have an X
chromosome because without one the rest
of your body doesn't develop why do we
call this the female chromosomes okay
this is something I'd never thought
about but literally every single person
in this audience has an X chromosome I'm
not lying
every single person on the planet has an
X chromosome but no one's going around
going like oh this is the every person
chromosome you know like frozen oh it's
over here like the Y's over there and
they must be really different and I'm
just like oh it'd be so much better
visually every person chromosome and not
just because I'm like love you all and I
want you all in but because of what
we're overlooking by the fact that we
consider it female because I'm gonna
tell you my one of the craziest things I
found out which is when you think about
the X chromosome of the almost 1100
genes on the X chromosome how many do
you think have to do with sex and
reproduction just like get a number in
your head 4%
i means 96% of the rest of it grow this
hope is doing something that has nothing
to do with your gonads and I guess as
all of these sort of some of them social
stories some of them scientific stories
some of these facts started to add up I
just thought like why are we calling
these the sex chromosomes or if we are
like maybe we all like that name should
we just allow ourselves to think about
them a little more broadly because if we
do like what insights would we gain as
people as scientists and we're at this
point where we're thinking about like
how do we want to teach science what do
we want to fund like who do we want to
be as a society you know and I just
wondered if it wasn't a moment to
rethink the biology of x and y and at
the very least to remember like the
footnotes of history which is that the
dude who came up with the phrase
sex chromosome actually was like hey
everyone just remember this is just and
I quote a form of shorthand we should
not take it literally
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]